[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الحرس الثوري الايراني
يعلن مقتل خمسه من مستشاريه العسكريين في
سوريا في غاره اسرائيليه على حي المزه
بدمشق ووسائل اعلام ايرانيه تقول ان من
بينهم قائد استخبارات فيلق القدس في ساحه
سوريا ونائبه في حين اعلن الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرض عقوبات على حركتي حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي بينما تتصاعد المظاهرات
في مدن وعواصم عده تضامنا مع الشعب
الفلسطيني وللتنديد بالحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب
غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول تقرير للامم
المتحده يفيد بان من بين 100 الا و15 الف
شخص قتلوا في مدينه الجنين السودانيه في
غرب دارفور العام الماضي جراء اعمال عنف
عرقيه نفذتها قوه الدعم السريع وميليشيات
متحالفه معها حسب التقرير الاممي رئيس
الوزراء الهندي يدشن معبدا هندوسيا على
موقع مسجد بابري الذي هدمه متشددون هندوس
عام
1992 وادت الى اندلاع اشتباكات اودت بحياه
نحو 2000 شخص اغلبهم من المسلمين في خطوه
وصفت بانها تجسد التوتر الطائفي وتعبر عن
سياسه مودي القوميه المحابي للهندوس
اليابان تصبح خمس دوله تنجح الهبوط على
سطح القمر بعد اعلان وكاله الفضاء
اليابانيه هبوط المسبار الفضائي سليم بدقه
غير مسبوقه حسب وصفها لكن الوكاله قالت ان
الواح المسبار الشمسيه لا تنتج الطاقه
حاليا مرجحه ان تعمل مجددا عندما تتغير
زاويه الشمس الى
اللقاء